meeting new people it's the spice of
life but sometimes you look all over the
kitchen and you don't know where the
spice rack is you need someone to show
you the way
so I'm gonna find two people and demand
that they hang out with each other all
day let's see how it goes
do you like meeting new people yes of
course I do
I'm from Australia so I'm going to tune
their loan new people yes sometimes
of course I'm antisocial people are
wonderful as long as they're nice if I
found someone random for you to hang out
with all day would you do it well I
would have to approve that randomness no
right now no I think so yeah great we
got our first person I'll be fine if
they're open to sitting down on the Sun
for a while I have my job and then gonna
party with me then they'll see how fun I
am at that scene we just came to where
we're supposed to meet up with Dustin he
didn't have a working cell phone here in
the US we'll see time to wait well
unfortunately our first guy we found
didn't show up so he had to get on the
bus and go back to square one how would
you feel about a random stranger joining
you for everything you do for the rest
of the day I would totally do that
I have Caitlin and Gary who have agreed
to hang out with each other all day I've
agreed almost she'd hi hey Caitlin you
for Australia I am from Australia what
are you doing here I'm a filmmaker and
my films playing intrigue fest don't
your movie about it's a horror comedy
about two girls who decide to do a Blood
Pact over I'm sleep over and then they
cut their hands cos stop bleeding anyway
listen I can't stay
I've got Caitlin and Bree came to hang
out all day go ahead and meet each other
hi Caitlin great lovely to meet ya I'm
going to the Museum of Death
yeah you happy to come to that I would
absolutely go with you to the perfect
and then I'm going to shrink fest later
to see some films play so are you guys
best friends yeah pretty much yeah
all right guys have a great day thanks
what's the museum of death oh my gosh
I'm so excited yeah we met that lovely
Australian going her American friend
Australia no and you know how to
embalming body yes that was very
interesting
does the cult group which is awesome
we're just finished somebody got a shirt
bag then we went to straight faster
opening that wait is that guy behind you
this Monday though yeah and we got a
pictures on the red carpet yeah what we
gonna do we're about to see a horror
movie from we're from Spain we're about
to see how Spain scares the crap out of
their people that was it it was well
made sweet bass you caught there to make
sure that you weren't kidnapped and he
told the guy like get her home safe yeah
and that dude looked at me like I was
joking and I was like no no I need to
make sure she's like alive tomorrow okay
so we just got to rim strangers to hang
out all day and they had a great time
and they're like basically best friends
now so you should go meet a stranger on
the street and tell them you're doing
whatever you're doing and see how it
goes
[Music]